If your email list feels dead, nobody
replies anymore, and your sales are
tanking, it is because you are violating
what I call the revenue reversal rule.
And it's the one thing that every
business who's blowing up with email
right now, like Golf Digest, TechCrunch,
Marketing Brew, Seth Godin, Daily Dad,
Daniel Throssell, they have figured this
one thing out. And in this video, I'm
going to explain the revenue reversal
rule alongside seven other new marketing
rules that you have to understand to win
this year. All right, let's dive in. The
revenue reversal rule, what does that
mean? Well, what it means is that
everybody who's focusing on revenue with
email is actually making less revenue.
Here's what's happening in our culture
is we are more fatigued of being sold to
than ever before. Think about how many
ads one person sees in one day, over
40,000 ads between Twitter, email,
YouTube, TV, all of these things. And
so, when you become a brand or a person
that just continuously markets to
someone, their loyalty to you decreases
while their fatigue increases. You are
reversing your desired effect and
repelling instead of selling. And so,
what is the cure for increasing revenue?
The flip to the revenue reversal rule is
don't focus on revenue, focus on
relationship. Oh, I know I just lost so
many of you. Oh, another relationship
guy. Listen, bear with me because the
thing that I'm going to do that no one
else does is I'm going to explain
how to focus on relationship. I'm going
to teach you how to do it. Starting with
the first thing is going
personality-based emails instead of
brand-based emails. I'm a personal
brand, Alan Drago. My YouTube channel
goes to Alan Drago's email list, so it's
very easy for me to have
personality-based emails. But a lot of
you guys run emails for clients, or you
have a brand that you send emails from.
Let me give you an example what
personality-based emails looks like in
that scenario. So, I used to write
emails for my friend Phil Bennelli who
runs Hope Well Farms. Before I came into
the picture, Hope Well Farms was sending
a weekly email, just like most people
do, from Hope Well Farms. And this is
the generic platitude style email that
is dying. He would send a weekly updated
email about what's happening on the
farm, discounts, what they sold, all
this good stuff, right? It looked like a
bulletin. But when I came in, I said,
"We're going to do things a little bit
differently. We're not going to make the
emails come from Hope Well Farms. We're
going to make the emails come from Phil
at Hope Well." So, what I did was I
injected Phil as the person behind the
brand. You could do this with any brand.
It could be the CMO, the CEO. It could
just be someone interesting on your
staff. Honestly, it doesn't have to be
someone who's hyping the company. It has
to be somebody with a lot of
personality. In my case, it just
happened to work out that Phil is a very
optimistic, bombastic, high-energy guy.
So, writing in his voice was super fun
and super easy. And instead of those
weekly bulletin emails, what we did was
we started telling stories behind the
brand, which leads me to point number
two. Stories over sales. Every week,
Phil would send from Hope Well a sale
that they were having, but we didn't
talk about the sales, because when all
you do is talk about the sales, people
don't buy from you until there is a
sale. But if you tell stories about the
brand and about their issues and their
problems, then people will buy based off
relationship and not based off
discounts. So, every week we'd be
sending emails about what was happening
at the farm, or we'd be making fun of
other brands who were selling an
inferior product and doing it at a
markup. We would tell these great
stories that would get people to reply
and nod their heads and be like, "Oh my
god, I saw that too, and that was
crazy." And it would get them to like
us, know us better, know what was
happening behind the scenes, and so they
built a relationship for us. And what
ended up happening is Hope Well Farms
used to get $100 to maybe $300 worth of
orders when they sent their email. Now,
this is a very tiny list, maybe 1,000
2,000 people at the time. Very tiny
list. But when we started doing our
personality-based story-based emails, we
increased the sales to 1,000 2,000 3,000
every week and it continued to grow
instead of spiking up and down. This is
the power of storytelling and
personality-based emails. People buy
people, not products. You have to get
that through your head. They're buying
you first and then they're buying the
product, which leads to number three
tactic of how you build a relationship
and that is you create an email
experience. Ben Settle calls this
world-building. One of the most tactical
and practical ways to build a world is
to write your emails in with settings
and characters that become familiar to
the reader. Think about Harry Potter,
right? You're always at Hogwarts and you
have Hermione and Harry and Ron and you
have these cast of characters that come
in and out. You're doing the same thing
but with email. So I created a cast of
characters with Hopewell Farms. You got
Farmer Phil, you got the farm dogs,
right? I always had the farm dogs who
are always doing crazy things on the
farm. I had his wife Lindsey and then I
had one of the farm workers named Ron
who was hilarious, always doing crazy
things at the farm. That experience that
you create becomes a world that people
become familiar with and even addicted
to being a part of. It's why novels do
so well. It's why sitcoms do so well
because you know Ross and Rachel and you
know Kramer and Elaine and you know
these people and you develop a
relationship with them beyond just the
person you're writing the emails from.
Then the next thing, number four, is
turn your emails into a saga. Instead of
every email being an individualized
story or an individualized sale or
experience or whatever it is, let the
stories build on top of each other. For
example, again, when I was writing for
Hopewell Farms, I told multiple stories
about how we were increasing the
equipment at the farm to be able to
process more chickens to be able to do
more sales and things like that, but I
turned it into a fun saga where the
wrong equipment was delivered and then
the guy installed it wrong and we had to
send it back and I turned it into this
hilarious saga that people were just
wondering, "When are you going to get
your new equipment installed?" So, we
took something seemingly boring that
could have been an update, "Hey, just so
you know, we have upgraded our equipment
to be this to process the We didn't do
any of that. We took that and we told
story after story after story, which got
people addicted to what was going to
happen next. That is one of the most
underrated ways to build an email list
that people continue to open and reply
and buy from is find a story that
contains a journey, a saga you want to
take them on and then use multiple
emails to create curiosity and open
loops to figure out what happens next,
which leads to number five, email more
often, not less often. Do you think
people are interested in hearing a story
or a saga that takes eight weeks to
finish? No, I can't email once a week.
In fact, I was emailing two, three,
four, five times a week for e-com
brands. For my personal brand, I email
every single day because I'm working on
my business every day, so I have stories
to tell every day. Emailing more often
increases your relationship with your
people, not decreases. Think about it.
If I had coffee with my wife every
Sunday at 8:00 a.m. and I just gave her
a wall of updates that happened in my
week and then I just left, do you think
my relationship with my wife would be
good or not so good? It would be not
It's not GOING TO BE GOOD. I'll tell you
that right now. It's not going to be
good. But, what if every morning I made
myself a cold brew, I got some sparkling
water, I sat her down and I said, "Hey,
babe, check this out. This is a
hilarious thing that happened to me
yesterday." We went, she replied, I
talked back and forth, and then we did
it again the next morning, and the next
morning, and the next morning. You have
to think about your email list as a
two-way conversation, and that when you
are emailing daily, or at least multiple
times a week, because what it does is it
continues to build the relationship. It
gives you an opportunity to tell more
stories, to build the experience that
gets them into your world more often.
And if you're using personality-based
story-driven emails exactly like I'm
telling you, you will do far better than
99% of the other brands who are just
shouting and touting discounts at
people. Which leads to number six, which
is minimal over mass. Emails that I send
and the biggest brands in the world are
sending are very simple emails. It is
mostly a plain text email with maybe an
image or two dropped in throughout. It's
not these beautiful design emails with
colors and blocks and all these things
that you send to a design team. No, it
looks like you honestly just opened
Gmail, started typing some stuff, maybe
threw in a picture or two, and sent it
off to grandma. Like your grandma should
be able to read your emails and think
that it was a one-to-one email based on
her. Because remember, this goes back to
the revenue over relationship. If people
are opening your emails and it feels
like a mass email, they're immediately
going to be turned off, and they're
going to archive it, they're going to
unsubscribe, they're going to move away
because they don't want to be marketed
to. It's the same thing like when you
get home and you take the mail out of
your mailbox, what do you do? You
instantly split your mail into two
piles, personal mail, marketing mail.
And what do you do with the marketing
mail? You immediately throw it in the
trash. You don't even open it. You open
the mail that looks personal. Email is
the exact same experience. And so when
you have a minimal approach to your
email designs, then you give yourself
and your readers the opportunity to get
sucked into your world, to get sucked
into your stories, and then become
addicted to not just today's email, but
tomorrow and the next day and the next
day, which leads me to the last point
that you need to write highly addictive
emails, and that is to have an insanely
recognizable
voice. Having a writing voice has never
been more important. More people are
using Claude and ChatGPT and all of
these things to write their content, and
what it is doing is it's making everyone
sound exactly the same. I mean, think
about it. Think if every business used
the same colors. Like McDonald's uses
red and yellow. What if Best Buy also
used red and yellow? What if Chipotle
also used red and yellow? What if every
brand you knew used red and yellow as
their brand colors? Well, you would look
at that and say, "Everybody looks the
same." And so, you can't really tell the
difference between all of these brands,
and your brain begins to neurologically
filter out all of the things that look,
feel, taste, smell, and see the same,
which is why today you have to sound
different. Whether it's your emails are
really funny, or you use dry humor, or
your emails are really short and spiffy
and fast, or whether you write very
sophisticated and smart. You have to
find that magic tone of yours that makes
people open it and immediately
recognize, "Oh, this is Phil from
Hopewell. This is Allan Dragoo." It's
never been more important to dial in
your voice. The best example of this was
the Wendy's Twitter girl. The girl who
was the writer behind Wendy's, what she
did was, instead of being every boring
brand on the internet, she had a savage
voice. She trolled everyone. She trolled
McDonald's, she trolled Starbucks. She
would make fun of every other fast food
restaurant from the Wendy's account, and
it was hilarious. And so, whenever
Wendy's tweeted, it was insanely
recognizable that it was Wendy's. When
you open my emails, it is insanely
recognizable that I wrote those emails.
They're very bombastic, they're funny,
they're loud, they have a lot of high
energy. But on the opposite side, if you
open an email from say Ryan Holiday,
they're very chill, they're very smart,
sophisticated, and written as if he is a
literature writer. You have to be able
to nail the voice. That's it. Those are
the seven, but I want to recap this
really quick. The first one is
personality-based emails instead of
brand-based emails. The second one is
stories over sales. Number three is you
need to create an experience, a world
that people can get sucked into. Number
four, you turn your emails into a saga,
multiple emails to tell one bigger
story. Number five is you email more
often, not less often. Number six,
minimal over mass design. And number
seven, have an insanely recognizable
voice. And one of the best resources
that I can give to nail all seven of
these is clicking the link down below
where I actually gift you the one email
that I wrote that got me over a thousand
subscribers in almost one night just
from this one email. It's highly
addictive, highly entertaining, and I
think it's going to shape the way that
you write emails from the for the future
just with this one email. So, grab it,
link in the description below. Like and
subscribe to the channel if you enjoyed
this video, and I will keep making great
content like this for you. I'll catch
you on the next one.